new research shows America's millennial
generation regaining its economic power
more than five years after the end of
the recession for America's young adults
employment is up wages are higher and
they may finally be moving out of mom
and dad's basement possibly owning their
own homes we're gonna be doing well John
well joining me from DC is Bloomberg's
victoria Stilwell who has been crunching
the numbers on this Victoria what was
most surprising that you found here
about the millennial generation and the
workplace yeah I think what's surprising
is that wages are rising for Millennials
which is kind of counter to this bad
news narrative that we also often hear
about them and they're rising faster
than that of the broader populations so
Wells Fargo crunch the numbers and
looked at some data when they looked at
as the four quarter moving average of
median weekly earnings suggest wage
growth here and what they found was for
16 to 24 year-olds wages grew 4.8% in
the fourth quarter from the year before
but that was faster than any other age
group it was doubled the second-fastest
earners also Millennials 25 to 34 year
olds clocking 2.4 percent wage growth so
that's a really good sign yeah yeah it
is a good sign is that a good sign for
the overall overall labor market yeah so
there is seems like they may be a little
bit of a canary in the coal mine and
economists over at the conference board
guide Lebanon found that we also saw
this pattern in the previous expansion
we got a nice pop in earnings for these
younger workers and that proceeded
faster pickup and wages for older
workers as well so if we do get this
this rising wage growth that's been
something that's been a listen link in
the economy that you know everyone from
Fed officials to just regular workers
are worried about so if we can see this
improvement that would really put us on
firmer footing and what how might we
start to feel this in the broader
economy Victoria I mean where are they
going to be putting this money towards
it's extra money that they seem to now
be earning well unfortunately a lot of
it is probably gonna have to be put
towards student loans we know that about
40% of households with an adult petabyte
an adult younger than 40 years old has
so at least some of that income is
probably going to have to be
appropriated toward paying down that
debt but we are also seeing signs that
they are forming households they are
moving out of probably mom and dad's
basement and they are going into rental
units it looks like no no real change in
fact the homeownership rate dropped in
the fourth quarter so they're not
becoming homeowners just yet but as we
know big steps here
will get them into rentals and then
hopefully if the economic growth that
we've seen in 2014 continues then they
can they can get there right they can
get to owning a home they'll save enough
money to possibly do that all right
Victoria thank you so much a Bloomberg
Victoria's Stillwell from DC